Okay Michael, so here's the first sort
of real example that I want to give you
and it's going to be in peer teaching,
which hopefully is near and
dear to some of our listener's hearts so
here's the idea.
The idea is that we've got a student.
Let's called the student curly,
and we've got a teacher.
Let's called his teachers smooth and
there's a bunch of questions, okay,
on some subject.
Pick a subject you like.
>> Dinosaurs.
Okay good, so if you want your questions
on dinosaurs, you should draw dinosaurs.
>> Okay.
There I've drawn
a dinosaur in white ink.
Okay, so what we have here is we have
a bunch of questions about dinosaurs
from the
>> It's a snow dynamicus.
>> A snow
>> [LAUGH] Okay, let's try that again.
So what we have is we have a bunch
of questions, and let's just say for
the sake of this discussion that
we can sort them, and order them
from really really easy questions
to really really hard questions.
And what I really mean
is that down here,
people with very little knowledge about
dinosaurs can answer people up here.
You really have to have
learned a lot about dinosaurs,
and it kind of moves between
the spectrum from easy to hard.
That make sense?
>> Yeah,
I guess as a coarse approximation.
>> Sure, and so
what we're trying to figure out and
this is important the goal
here is to figure out
what incentives we can give to both
the student and to the teacher.
So that learning happens over time so
the goal is learning and
what we need to do is design mechanism.
And mechanism in this setting means
like a payoff function essentially.
>> Yeah,
because we're talking game theory, so
in the end we're always going to be
talking about some kind of payoff.
Some way providing utility for taking
some kinds of actions in the world.
>> Now, it's important course this
is not just simply a one shot game.
This really is a case that room will
be taking actions over a period
of time because of course learning is
going to happen over a period of time.
And we want to figure out how
we're going to get someone to
kind of get out these questions.
This is all we've got right.
We've got learning, we got a teacher,
we got a bunch of questions we know
they're easier or easy and hard and
we're going to try to figure out
what we want the teacher to do.
And what we want to learner to do so
the learning happen, okay.
So we need to design a mechanism
that will ensure the goal.
>> And
just to be clear is your assumption that
answering questions actually helps
you learn or is this just assessment?
>> This is a sort of assessment.
This is assessment but of course if
you can reliably answer questions
then it suggests that
you know something.
Okay.
>> Does that make sense?
>> Yeah, I guess I'm just
wondering to what end, right?
So, what kind of questions
should be asked.
>> Ones that help me to figure
out that you've learned.
>> That you've learned.
>> Yeah.
>> Okay.
>> Now,
other stuff can be happening here.
And there's you know
whole complicated things.
Readings can happen in between.
There can be tutorials or whatever but
we're trying to make this game really
sort of simple to illustrate the idea.
So in between questions
things might happen.
>> Okay.
>> And
perhaps answering the question
requires that you go off and
you do some reading or do some work.
>> Which could promote some learning.
Some of these questions might be.
Take implement five supervised
learning algorithms on two
datasets that are interesting run them
and write a talker to say for example.
>> My gosh,
that's a terrible assignment.
>> Yeah, but
you will learn something in.
>> Yeah, you'll learn that some
people give terrible assignments
that cause you to learn.
I think that's what
really important here.
>> So are you with me?
Kind of understand what it is
we're trying to accomplish here?
>> I think so, yeah.
>> Okay, cool.
>> So let me give you a proposal for
some instances and you tell me
what you think is going to happen.